Crows represent order.
Security.
Safety.
Batman gave up on us.
The bad's not coming back.
Something's up. Eyes everywhere.
Hello said Alice.
Shall we believe the Crows will protect us?
Agent Moore, do you copy?
Do you copy?
Sophie's missing.
I thought you should know.
Hey, dad.
We're gonna find her.
Then, let me help.
Bad idea.
Where'd you get this?
What happened to staying out of it?
Is there something you'd like to report to your squad?
Don't run in without proper backup.
I do not want her getting in the way.
Curiouser and curiouser.
What do you want?
I need you to send your father a message.
You're all I have left, Kate.
And I don't want to lose you too.
Wayne Security.
You owe my boss a new door.
Your boss is my cousin.
You don't wanna go near that.
You're seriously not supposed
to know what's down there.
So, I have this thing with rules...
I need you to fix his suit.
The suit is literal perfection.
It will be,
when it fits a woman.
You're a female Bruce Wayne.
Awesome, hilarious, handsome.
Look! It's Batman!
They think I'm him.
I'm not about to let a man
take credit for a woman's work.